hey guys today I'm bringing something
way different that I've been uploading
so far by now this video is not like my
other usual videos it's on a theory
video or video about season 7 news
that's reason of leaning on my usual
spoiler warning at the beginning of this
video today I'm going to talk about
honourable acts of two characters Ned
Stark and Jaime Lannister I know the
most of you right now don't even wanting
a sinner Jaime as an honorable man
at least not compared to Ned Stark but
after this video you might change your
mind I'm fully aware of Jaime's few
dishonourable and really bad acts like
throwing branch rod we know who in favor
to save his sister's pride but you have
to admit the veal hated Jaime only
because of his act in the first season
but since the third season Jaime grew in
our eyes with very much honourable acts
of heads especially with real aiming the
true background story and the true
reasons of his betrayal or the King
Aerys Targaryen which he told to Brienne
it's important for you to know that I
don't want to humble or point out the
honor of either Jaime or Ned I'm going
to compare a few of the rags and point
out some differences let's start with
Jaime Lannister on one hand a lot of
people consider Jaime as an honorable or
even more honourable than Ned without
making any mistake but only from one
view which this fact kind of confirms
the net was finally engaged Sir Arthur
Dayne which Ned would have lost if he
along with his companions didn't now
number the best swordsman that the Seven
Kingdoms has ever had and if they knew
that he didn't kill Howland Reed but
only had wounded him the important
outcome of that fight is at the swirl of
the morning got stabbed from the back by
Holland breed which ended with Ned
killing him the net killed Sara her no
matter circumstances no matter the
Navitus companions greatly outnumbered
Sir Arthur Dayne and no matter that how
I read coverless tied him from behind
a matter of any of those circumstances
Ned Stark decided to finish him distance
fight against Sara ordained we're going
to compare Jaime's fight against Ned
Stark and there are a few big
differences when Jamie came a dozen
Lannister soldiers to find Ned Stark
cause with his four or five soldiers
almost same scenario happened but with a
few important differences while let's
start with his companions killed the
only one warrior that fooled by Sir
Arthur Dayne side them all
of them then attacked sir ordained and
there's a huge difference in Jamie's
fight Jamie uses his Lancer soldiers on
the cane as protectors and then Jamie
and TechNet alone and font alone against
and stark no matter that he could have
used all dozen slender soldiers because
the ratio is also the same compared to
Nats fight against her Archer but Jamie
won even fair fight he wanted to fight
one-on-one that's one difference between
those two fights but the second
difference is huge and could I find
Jamie as vain more honorable man than
Ned just like mr. Archer gets tired on
the bag by Reed this time I have a staff
from the back by one Lancer soldier only
this time Jamie didn't want any man to
interrupt his fight against Ned
furthermore after the only Lannister
soldiers dead in that slag Jamie nailed
him so hard that he fell on the ground
because as Jamie's face in that scene
says itself Jamie wanted as I've already
said fair one-on-one fight this is the
moment in which we've seen difference
between Jaime Lannister Ned Stark the
main difference is in this fact which is
fairness
while Ned decided to kill wounded Sir
Arthur Dayne after he got stabbed from
the back Jamie didn't want to kill Ned
Stark after he also got stabbed in the
back because as Jamie said to his father
it wouldn't have been clean kill now you
see this huge difference between Jamie's
and that attack in those two fights
right Jamie considered killing Ned who
got stabbed from the back by someone
else as dishonorable act well and killed
Sir Arthur Dayne also got stabbed from
the back after they covered Lee
outnumbered him this is the only one way
of the view as I said in the beginning
of this video there are a few sights of
view at these fights on the other hand
some people could also see a scene in
which net kill Sir Arthur Dayne as Nance
mercy towards him some could even
consider it as Sir Arthur's request to
finish him let me explain why we
consider it that Sir Arthur's request
when they was starting nak from the back
he understood that he's going to die
from blood choking and bleeding that's
why Sir Arthur through his famous word
in front of Ned Stark it could mean that
word of the morning shall I say
requested from that start to save him
from the pain and to give him a quick
death it could also mean since he was
the great sportsman that the Seven
Kingdoms has ever had that he didn't
want to be killed by some morning man by
some more in blade it could mean that
the fame and legend
nightshroud her name was known as word
of the morning might want to be killed
by a hero in that rebellion by Ned Stark
and to be killed by the most famous War
in Seven Kingdoms
but his famous ancestral grades were
called dawn as I've said in the
beginning of this video but I want to
humble any of those characters honour
but Jaime Lannister and Ned Stark could
and should be considered as the man of
honor
Ned Stark is honorable because the many
things he had done in his life
we would highlight nets promised to his
sister Lyanna is the most honorable
thing that Ned did in his life
Ned presented John as his own son in
favour to protect him he kept his
promise to his sister throughout his
whole life I didn't even tell his own
wife about John's real mother Catelyn
Stark lasts only once about John's
matter which not ask for coldly with
never asked me about John he is my blood
and that's all you need to know
unbelievable but honourable that didn't
pronounce any line his answer John
actually has Ned's blood since Nana
since uncle there are as I learned
mentioned a lot of honorable things than
I did throughout his life but promised
that he gave to his sister and kept
throughout his whole life is that from
the most honourable one while on the
other side Jaime also did a lot of
horrible acts throughout his life the
most important one is saving thousands
of innocent lives by killing the Mad
King Jaime Lannister's for this sag the
true hero but still Hollister still
doesn't respect him furthermore they're
mocking him by calling him Kingslayer
yeah he killed the King whom he was
supposed to guard with his own life but
the only reason of Jaime killing King
Aerys Targaryen is because the King's
intention to burn the whole King's
Landing along with all people within it
Jaime should be respected by every
living man and woman in King's Landing
but he doesn't want to prove to everyone
else the real reason for his let's call
it betrayal or the Mad King because he
thoughts are that it wouldn't change
other people's opinion about him since
no one would believe him actually can
call Jaime's act as betrayal over the
King Gary's since he was also sworn to
protect innocent people lives which he
did by killing Mad King here's the
important fact that all of you should
know Jaime didn't decide to betray King
Aerys not even after Kings troops lost
the battle and battlefield Jimmy also
counseled the Mad King not to open the
King's Landing case for his own father
Damian Lannister because Jamie knew that
he
father would betray the king from the
other honorable acts rod James life we
would highlights am Brienne of Tarth
twice the first time James Abraham from
being raped by Bolton soldiers which led
to Jaime losing his hand in our opinion
who James stayed out from everything and
didn't lie about Bryan's father's wealth
in favor to save her from being raped he
wouldn't have made law angry over his
own arrogance which wouldn't result in
Jaime losing his hand since they would
have had fun with Brienne the second
time rain was thrown into gladiator pit
given only witness war to fight against
the bear as a result of lucky finding
out the gem lie to him about bran
fathers well once again jaemin ran it he
jumped into the pit and with the help of
steel shanks who was bound by his duty
to ensure Jaime's arrival in King's
Landing
Jaime and Brienne somehow managed to
escape from the pit in our opinion both
Jamie and Ned are the true definition of
honorable man both but on different ways
I'm aware that some of you don't want to
consider Jaime as an honorable man
mostly because of his incest with his
sister here's the one fact for all of
you
house 3 games doing incest are the most
of their history but however many of
them were or even our heroes in the eyes
of many people so what's the difference
to conclude this Ned Stark and Jaime
Lannister should be respected by all of
us and by all the people in Westeros
because if there are many honorable acts
throughout their lives well Jamie still
have a plenty time to do many honourable
things firstly he need to understand who
his sister and lover really is and for
whom he should fight
I'm sure the Jim is going to play the
main role in season 7 and that he's
going to do many honorable things in the
upcoming seasons
the important thing for Jamie is to
realise that his sister the same lunatic
as the Mad King was and to realize that
he killed the king whom he was supposed
to defend because of his intention to
murder the King's Landing which Circe
actually have done in previous season
I'm aware that Aerys Targaryen attendant
to burn down the whole King's Landing
but still serves to killed a lot of
innocent people by destroying the great
Sept of Baelor those same Ian's and
people whom Jaime once protected from
the King Aerys while there were a lot of
speculations about Jaime's loyalty to
Cersei after the season 6 finale after
James look to our Cersei on the Iron
Throne with a lot of disappointment in
his eyes
after Havana that his sister and lover
Circe is the Wildfire to destroy one
part of King's Landing along with many
innocent people which also led to their
son's suicide
we thought that Jaime would immediately
break every connection between them in
the upcoming season but from the leaked
photos we can still see Jaime fighting
on the Lannister side but beware that
this doesn't mean that he will forgive
Cersei for what she has done in our
opinion Jaime is going to hate Circe in
the upcoming season but still he is a
Lannister he isn't some servant of
sources that could just go away
Jaime's lannister and is going to do
everything he can to save his house from
disappearing in the next few days I'm
going to make a video about Jamie's fate
in season 7 supported by all leaked
photos leaked plot and of course with
few tears of mine if you like this kind
of video that I brought you today let me
know in comment section down below